(audience cheering)
- Hello there.
- Goodness hi!
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] I would wear that.
- I would wear this.
- I feel like I should
be on a beach somewhere.
If we would like to just leave
now and go, it would feel-
- I would follow you to that beach.
- Yeah, so have y'all met before?
- No.
- I don't know if you've ever met before.
- But I admire your work.
- Likewise.
- You devoured "White Lotus".
- Oh my goodness, thank you so much.
I'm obsessed.
This is wild.
- It is a wild thing.
Wait, I love finding out
that you are musical.
So did you do musical theater growing up?
Did you?
- I did, barely in high school.
I'm what you call a karaoke person
versus someone who's just like,
"Oh yeah, I sing professionally",
'cause it's terrifying.
- But when you get terrified?
- I get terrified because I feel like-
- That's how I get acting.
- What?
- Exactly, I could sing in front
of billions of people and be like,
(Kelly making trumpet sounds)
- [Natasha] Yeah.
- But if I have to act,
I want to full on my pants.
- Yes, yes, yes, yes, no, no, no, no, no.
Clean up on aisle, me
- Clean up on aisle this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I get so nervous and
that's why I don't do it
'cause I don't enjoy it.
- I just love the acting so much,
when I was in high school,
and so I wanted to be in everything.
So it's just like the musical everything.
But I auditioned for "Music
Man", when I was a junior.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And my best friend at the
time was hearing impaired
and I wanted to understand
her world better.
So I taught myself ASL.
And so I was like-
- That's cool.
- "I will sign the song that I sing
for this audition 'cause
at least it'll distract me
from the the pressure of singing."
- That's beautiful.
- It was in theory.
So-
- Oh.
- What happened was during
the audition I got nervous
as I predicted and forgot the sign
but my hands were in the air
and I committed by just
doing interpretive dance.
(audience laughing)
(Kelly laughing)
Yeah.
- That's amazing.
- So I just kind of danced
along to what I was singing.
- You just moved your hands.
- Yeah and what put it over of the edge
was the crying that happened.
- Oh no.
- As I was dancing with
my hands in the air.
- 'Cause you were like,
♪ I'm going down ♪
- Yes, yes, it was rough stuff,
but I made the musical guys.
(audience cheering)
I made the musical.
That's right, that's right.
I was in the chorus.
I was in the deep chorus.
They don't create deep chorus nowadays,
but my teacher created one for me.
- That's amazing, wait, have
you ever had that moment
on stage where you just,
it didn't go as planned?
- Constantly.
- [Kelly] Yeah, okay.
- I'm a 50, 50 actor at best.
(all laughing)
- Oh my God.
I had a moment like that in high school.
I had one in high school and it was like,
everyone was so loud and everyone's like,
"Oh she can hit whistle notes."
So I was like, "Put a
whistle note in the song."
I was like, "Okay, cool."
But they started yelling so loud
that I couldn't hear the song.
- [Natasha] Oh no.
- So I did hit a note just
in a key for another song.
Like a key.
And I fled to like the
closest closet I could find
and just was like, you
know, you're in high school.
You're like, "It is over."
- Yeah, your life ends
when you mess up, yeah.
- It was so big, now it's just funny.
- Yes.
Now I can laugh about it.
- Now I'm just like-
- But I also learn like,
(Kelly screaming)
- It's like,
- Yeah, you just, when you audition
for something, just be yourself.
Don't try to do too much.
I did not know that then.
- That's kinda very thoughtful though
that you had a friend, that's really cool.
- Yeah, Sarah Dubner she's
out there still, yeah.
- Ah, still waiting for that performance.
- I know.
(all laughing)
I'm still working on
it, still working on it.
- We will do this for you, Sarah.
So your new movie, I loved the
original "Sonic The Hedgehog"
was played so much in our
house, this one will as well.
So thank you for that for a new movie.
But the new movie, so what's it about?
- Well, we get to see
Sonic in a new world,
playing and doing the
things that we saw before
but it's bigger, badder and faster.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- My character is Rachel and
my sister is Maddie played
by the incredible Tika Sumpter.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And my fiance is Shemar Moore.
(audience cheering)
- I know I'm interviewing him
for the movie as well, yeah.
- I may or may not have had a calendar
of him when I was 16, on my wall.
- Dreams do come true.
- They do.
They really, really do.
And so when the director called me
and he was just like,
"We'd love to have you
back for the second movie.
How do you feel about playing
opposite Shemar Moore?"
Then there was a Natasha size
hole in my wall where I ran.
(all laughing)
He's like, "We're not shooting just yet."
And then I ran back home and I was like,
"All right cool."
- I'm ready.
- I'm ready, lets do it!
- You are so funny in the first one.
So I just, literally,
I love when people make
like films like this that
are for kids and adults,
we all enjoy it at the same time.
- It's for everybody.
- It's really cool of y'all to do for us.
'Cause some of them aren't for adults
and you're like, "Oh my gosh."
- [Natasha] Yeah.